been dating my boyfriend for almost a
year um and things have been going
really well but I have concerns that as
you know things continue to progress
hopefully down the path towards marriage
that our discrepancy in finances um
specifically income debt retirement
savings um will be a problem um and that
ultimately I might kind of find myself
in in a sugar mama type situ a which
really um you don't want be that girl so
uh how old are you I'm 38 and he is 35
okay cool and what do you make I make
200 and he makes 45 okay all right and
what does he do um he works in
construction MH and what do you do uh I
work in the automotive industry okay
there's nothing wrong with anything
you've told me so far that uh makes us
incompatible as long as you're both in
agreement